my dyslexia really helped me become a  really good delegator and i think  and that's been one of my great  strengths so  i i've had to find brilliant people  around me  over the last 50 years and all the  different ventures we've done  [Music]  and  be willing to give them a lot of freedom  freedom to  do good things and freedom to make  mistakes and um  and by and large it's worked and and  that's freed me up to you know worry  about  you know um the next hyperloop one well  the the next projects but also just to  look after oneself you know and look up  you know spend time with one's family  and  and be ready to troubleshoot when  something goes wrong  so not to get bogged down by the my new  tie